chyna you said in the past that china
poses one of the biggest strategic
challenges to the United States when
does that challenge become a threat some
ways that's just words on words right
it's a threat today it's a threat to our
businesses and our economy that is
they're a big competitor with some trade
arrangements that clearly disadvantage
the United States from the CIS
perspective we're watching and tracking
closely their capacity to grow their
military to advance their technological
capabilities we're very concerned about
China's cyber capacity as well they're a
very capable cyber foe also the SIA has
an enormous role in making sure we
understand how they're advancing the
technologies they're interested the work
that they're doing when our Chinese who
come to the United States who are
working on behalf the United States
government we have an obligation to make
sure we deliver to the FBI the
information they need so that we can
protect American property intellectual
and otherwise from those threats so
there's an important role at helping
policymakers understand the China
challenge and in turn delivering the
president options to push back against
that but we just learned this week that
that our intelligence shows six Chinese
ships were caught secretly aiding North
Korea I mean violating sanctions what
are they doing I mean that doesn't sound
like the Chinese are being helpful
so it's imperfect there's there's no
doubt there's work yet to do we think
that many countries China included
Russia even more particularly could do a
lot more on the pressure campaign and
all of us certainly the State Department
but all of us in the United States
government urging every country to
participate to what we view as a global
threat not just a threat to the United
States of America when Kim jong-un gets
a long-range capability if you draw the
circle it's not just the United States
that is at risk but Kim jong-un and his
scientists need fuel in order to launch
these missiles and weapons they do and
our the Chinese and the Russians helping
them get that fuel doing our best doing
our best to make sure that the UN
restrictions are in place and are
enforced there's lots of US activity or
to make that happen but the very fact
that you know about these the very fact
that you know that there were these
issues that have been reported in open
press not to suggest that the United
States government ought just sitting
back and watching all this